>>> A JURY RIGHT NOW HAS THE
STEVE BANNON CASE AND BEGAN
DELIBERATING ABOUT 40 MINUTES
AGO AFTER A CLIMATIC FINAL DAY
OF ARGUMENTS.
PROSECUTORS CLOSING OUT SAYING
BANNON SHOWED DEFIANCE
NO-SHOWING A FEDERAL SUBPOENA.
BANNON'S TEAM INJECTING
POLITICS.
SARAH, TELL US MORE.
>> Reporter: THAT IS RIGHT.
THE JURY IS DELIBERATING.
IT COMES AFTER THE PROSECUTION
LAID OUT A SIMPLE CLOSING SAYING
THIS IS A GUY THAT DID NOT SHOW
UP AND CHOSE HIS ALLEGIANCE OVER
DONALD TRUMP OVER THE LAW AND HE
DEFIED THE SUBPOENA.
HE DOES NOT BELIEVE THE RULES
APPLY TO HIM COMPARING IT TO A
PARKING TICKET, A RELEVANT
ANALOGY SAYING YOU CAN PAY IT
AND APPEAL AND IF THE GOVERNMENT
REJECTS YOUR EXCUSE, YOU HAVE TO
PAY IT.
YOU DON'T GET TO SNUB IT AND
WALK AWAY.
A ROCKY CLOSING FOR THE DEFENSE.
A LOT OF ARGUMENTS WERE
FORECLOSED ON THEM FROM THE
JUDGE, OBJECTION AFTER OBJECTION
AND ARGUED SOMETIMES PEOPLE TRY
TO SILENCE THEIR POLITICAL
CRITICS ARGUING STEVE BANNON IS
ISN'T.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT ALL SITS WITH
THE JURY.
IT WENT TO THEM AROUND
LUNCHTIME.
IF BANNON IS CONVICTED HE FACES
30 DAYS BEHIND BARS BUT IT
ALREADY APPEARS HIS LAWYERS ARE
WORKING TOWARDS AN APPEAL EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE WAITING FOR THE
VERDICT.
ELLIOTT, IT WAS A QUICK TRIAL.
HE GOT A SUBPOENA.
HE TRIED TO APPEAL IT.
HE WAS TOLD NO AND DEFIED IT.
DO YOU SEE ANY WIGGLE ROOM FOR
THE JURY OR IS IT CLEAR-CUT?
>> IT IS NOT RACKETEERING.
IT IS NOT A BIG CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY.
YOU ARE PROVING EFS WAS THERE A
SUBPOENA AND DID HE KNOW IT AND
VIOLATE IT KNOWINGLY.
THERE IS A PATH TO OBJECTING TO
A SUBPOENA.
YOU BRING IT TO THE COURT.
EVERY PROSECUTOR IN HISTORY HAD
THEIR HEART BROKEN BY A JURY YOU
THOUGHT SOMETHING SEEMED OBVIOUS
AND STRAIGHTFORWARD.
THE CRIME HERE IS
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND SIMPLE.
>> LET ME GET YOUR TAKE ON LAST
NIGHT.
A LOT OF THE CONVERSATION AMONG
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THEY BELIEVE THEY HAVE LAID OUT
A CASE FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
YOU ARE A TAD MORE SKEPTICAL
THERE.
I WANT TO GET YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
THEY DID MAKE CLEAR YOU HAVE TO
PROVE DONALD TRUMP KNEW CERTAIN
THINGS.
WITHIN 10 OR 15 MINUTES OF
GETTING BACK, HE KNEW AND HE
COULD SEE ON TELEVISION AND
PEOPLE CAME TO HIM THERE WAS
VIOLENCE AT THE CAPITOL.
WE KNEW FROM WATCHING HIS TWEETS
CARRIED POWER AND THAT PEOPLE IN
THE CROWD WERE READING AND
LOOKING AT TWEETS AS HE WENT.
AND WE GOT THIS FROM THE TOP
MILITARY OFFICIAL.
THE VICE PRESIDENT CALLED.
PEOPLE ON CAPITOL HILL CALLED.
NOT DONALD TRUMP.
>> THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF, YOU
HAVE AN ASSAULT GOING ON ON THE
CAPITOL OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
NOTHING?
NO CALL, NOTHING, ZERO?
>> IT IS A GLIMPSE AT THE
CHARACTER OF DONALD TRUMP.
YOU CAN ONLY SHAKE YOUR HEAD AT
IT.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WATCHING HAPPILY AS AN
ATTACK ON HIS GOVERNMENT
UNFOLDED.
YOU DON'T SEE ANY NEW WOW PIECES
OF CRIMINAL EVIDENCE.
>> THAT IS NOT TO SAY THEY WERE
NOT THERE BEFORE.
YOU HAVE A CLEAR PATH TO
OBSTRUCTING CONGRESS AND
CONSPIRACY AGAINST THE UNITED
STATES.
IT IS A TOUGHER PATH TO THINGS
LIKE INCITING THE CROWD BASED ON
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU HAVE.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT
THE PROUD BOYS WERE CONSPIREING
WITH EACH OTHER AND OATHKEEPERS
TO ENGAGE IN ACTS OF VIOLENCE.
YOU HAVE A TOUGHER PATH TO THE
PRESIDENT.
HIM WATCHING AT 1 P:39 P.M.
HIS KNOWLEDGE HE COULD GET TO
HIM IF HE WANTED.
THAT IS WHAT YOU NEEDED TO
ESTABLISH TO GET TO AN
INCITEMENT CHARGE.
I AM SAYING THE EVIDENCE THAT
CAME OUT YESTERDAY DID NOT ADD
ANYTHING NEW, NOT TO SAY THERE
WAS NOT PLENTY OF EVIDENCE IN
THE RECORD IN THE SIX HEARINGS
PRIOR TO LAST NIGHT.